do you own sheep yes and you commune
with the Sheep that's putting it too
strongly there's a a pond where I wash
and there's a sauna would find sauna so
we go down there and get in the sauna
and but in the summer I walk to and from
with nothing on one night there was a
kind of real thundering on the door of
our of our place and and it's miles away
from anywhere so I thought oh God okay
the man in The Mask has come to takes
away and I was there on my own with my
little daughter and we went downstairs
and opened the doors a massive and very
good looking policeman outside who said
um I'm so sorry to um to interrupt your
evening uh Mrs Thompson but Tim we've
had reports of an intruder on your land
um a woman was walking her dog and she
saw a 52 year old man coming naked up
through the seat
my boobs dropped so low that from a
distance they read as testicles